And I think this side-by-si
o and
Mott &
Manufacturing processes and they are half the price of other premium
Brands and you can actually buy like a couple different sizes of jeans
A
Now today I've actually gotten two pairs of jeans
These are genuine, finite, homegrown,
A Black pair of jeans. That actually does have a o comfy.
I have these crappy little pants. Look at this. They ripped from my phone in my pocket. Alright, I'm gonna try these on now.
I think these are gonna fit really well.
Nick: These pants have got to go son.
Wren: I know look at that
Wren: Oh My---
Nick:Get them Out of here.
Wren: Dude look at this! They're so stretchy.
If I was as stretchy as my pants, I'd do the splits. I'm not that stretchy.
Click the link below or go to mottandbow.com/CorridorCrew to get 20% off on your first purchase.
Wren: I don't like where this is going.
Clint: Nice and slow
Wren: Dude I'm about to fall down some stairs
Just got to get in there. Wren, Look. I promise, wait they're playing smash bros.